- Well, I'm a huge "Parks
and Recreation" fan
and I have a very embarrassing confession.
I told him backstage,
but in 2011 I tweeted,
I didn't just tweet,
I begged to be on "Parks and Recreation"
just so I could be in a
scene with Ron Swanson
because I was obsessed.
Here's the thing.
I even owned that I was a horrible actor.
I'm a horrible actor.
But I have a lot of spirit
(audience laughs)
and I could've played
a bad actor.
I didn't get a call, it's fine, it's fine.
Amy, it's fine, y'all.
No, but if we could
turn back time with Cher
and you gave me a role,
- If we could find a way.
- what do you think I could've played?
Maybe a stage five
cleaner for Ron Swanson.
- It's a huge compliment, first of all.
I'm very grateful that you
wanted to be on the show.
- Dude, it's great, it was so great.
There's so many great actors on there.
- I was grateful to get
to go to work every day
and I think great comedy
writers, they look at me
and they say, "We can make
people laugh with this.
"With these raw materials.
(Kelly laughs)
"Give that guy a coffee cup.
"Oh yeah, here we go.
"Give him a phone on his belt."
- You know what, the
physical comedy is so key.
- It is.
- That's what's so great.
- But I think they would look at you.
So they take your strengths
and they would say,
"Okay, let's cast Kelly
as a very enthusiastic,
"wildly enthusiastic
hurricane of positivity."
- Yes.
- And I think the laugh
to get with a Kelly Clarkson character is
someone who would out-Leslie
Knope Leslie Knope.
- Exactly.
- You would finally--
- Where were you in 2011?
- Someone would go too far.
- I'm just kidding.
- Somebody who Leslie Knope
would be like, "She's too much."
- [Kelly] She's a little
over the top.
- She's too excited.
- You know what, not the
first time I've heard that.
Probably not the last.
My husband says it every night
and then he says, "I love you."